I
good evening good evening so after
wonderful cocktail and beef wellington
and all the rest I think it's time to
bring our Hillsdale meeting together
thank you my name is Gary Brooks and not
really quite sure why I'm the MC today
you go on the radio and Hugh Hewitt and
Mark Levin and Rush Limbaugh and Hilary
elder and my goodness laura ingram
dennis prager they're all talking about
this wonderful place called hillsdale
college and as president dr. Larry
aren't but I have something they don't
have I'm a graduate of Hillsdale 1971 so
I guess that's why I'm up here so thanks
for sharing the evening with me I'm
pleased to welcome you all on behalf of
the college and my fellow host committee
members before we begin because of
today's modern world if you have a cell
phone as I did the other day I forgot it
was on and was embarrassing so take a
moment we'll wait and put them on bright
vibrator off okay would you please I
thank you would everybody please join me
and stand will give you time we're going
to do the Pledge of Allegiance please
all right and well there it is so there
we go and we'll begin please I pledge
allegiance the flag of the United States
if you the Republic for which it stands
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all thank you as
we begin to now like to introduce a
number of people in the audience tonight
first I would like to ask my fellow host
committee members to stand they are all
listed in the program they do a lot of
work they bring a lot of good folks out
would you all stand please thank you
very much thank you in addition which
makes us such a warm gather and we have
several alumni and parents with us in
addition to members of our presidents
club now our presidents club are
individuals who've made a substantial
gift to hillsdale college and I'm very
proud to say at this point we have
around 2,300 members of our presidents
club and I'd like to ask all of our
alumni our parents and presidents club
members to stand please and be
recognized and thank
hillsdale college as in the day when I
attended has 1300 students from 48
states seven foreign countries and of
these we have 55 students from the state
of California I'd like to introduce to
admission people for us Colleen McGinnis
and Kyle Myrna where the right over here
and there and most important for Colleen
and Kyle they're here to answer
questions and will be available later
and I had a chance to talk to a nice
young lady over here and smart some
prospective students those who've been
accepted to hillsdale college and those
that are looking to apply to hillsdale
college and so please you will find
these most helpful wonderful people make
yourself available as they are to you
okay we've got a few housekeeping items
we usually do before we have our
featured speaker dr. Larry yarn speak
first of all his remarks will be
videotaped and you will have the
opportunity to have this sent to you
free of charge so there's the
registration table when you came in go
up there later and they will be sure to
let you have the video of tonight's
speech after the program i'm going to
ask a few people to come to the stage
and they'll have their picture with dr.
aren these are our new presidents club's
members daniel burger Charles and Gail
kindle Jeff and Margie Lewis and Jeff
and chow Werner so after we'll have dr.
Arnn speech and a few question and
answer at the end of that if you would
come up we will take those pictures as
the rest of us go get our dessert and
coffee so you'll be only ones standing
around we've got some wonderful friends
that always surround Hillsdale College
two of them of which tom phillips and
tom fuentes at regency books of eagle
publishing and they've provided a gift
for each of us tonight they're booked
the funding father's the unsung heroes
of the conservative movement its authors
Nicole hopland and ron robinson and this
book if you haven't read it and hope is
something you can look for
two highly recommended by ed Meese and
Dinesh socha de socio so it's a
tremendous book again it's it's there
for you please take a copy and take it
with you now for tonight's program most
of you in the room know about in Primus
the college's national speech digest
since it was first mailed to one
thousand alumni 1972 that was the year I
became an alumni there were a thousand
of them sent out it reprints speeches
delivered on campus and at national
seminars by such influential people such
as Ronald Reagan Charlton Heston
Margaret Thatcher edwin meese david
mccullough and many many more it now has
a circulation approaching 1.9 million
including nigel including by the way
this great state of California with
239,000 of those so despite what you
read out of some papers like the
Sacramento Bee we have two hundred and
thirty-nine thousand of those in Primus
so fax will get in the way of everything
else if you would like any family
members and friends to receive this
subscription please again go the
registration desk fill it out and
they'll be happy to send you in Primus
those that you're getting it and I
assume that's about eighty or ninety
percent of this group it's tremendous
reading it comes from the people who
spoke at the college or through
outsourced events tremendous reading and
we encourage you to avail it to others
who do not have it and certainly if
you're not on the list it's very simple
to do all of this literature is free
it's it's available for you so please
notify the staff this year in keeping a
team with the communication level of
emails hillsdale is trying to really
upstage their email capability so
they're asking any of you who are not
set up for email with the college to
again sign up today and I encourage you
to go the registration table it's a
great way to receive more updates from
the college on both national and and
campus issues so I think we can all
appreciate where emails are today and
he'll
still wants to keep you in the program
for those of you that don't know and I
can't imagine that be hillsdale's a
small liberal arts college located
Michigan I'm from Michigan people say
where is Hillsdale College well it's
right here that's backing off but you
have to be from Michigan to know about
your map it has an ever-widening
reputation it sets it far apart from its
small humble beginnings in this small
little college town it leads the
nation's besides offering its students a
rigorous liberal arts curriculum and
privately funded tuition assistance it
is fiercely fiercely independent the
hillsdale college board of trustees and
president larry aaron have kept the
college free from direct and indirect
taxpayer subsidies as well as taxpayer
subsidies from the state of Michigan
Hillsdale does not now have any
government regulation or control it does
not have to and the reason it doesn't
because it doesn't take one bloody dime
of money and we ought to all be proud of
that on to dr. Larry yarn he is
hillsdale's 12th president over its rich
165 year history he is not a slouch let
me inform you he studied and worked in
England with sir martin gilbert the
official biographer of winston churchill
and each year and i've attended one of
these classes he teaches at Hillsdale
College the word waiting in line was
established for that class you can
imagine how many students would like to
be in that classroom with the president
of such a fine University does this
every year since becoming president of
Hillsdale College and year two thousand
he's found at the college's Hoagland
Center for Teaching Excellence a seminar
program which is so critically important
it brings school government and economic
teachers to the school and promotes the
principles of the Constitution in
addition dr. Arnn
has initiated the Hillsdale College
distinguished visiting fellows program
which again brings to the campus
teachers with such impressive people to
interact with as Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas Churchill biographer sir
martin gilbert military historian victor
davis hanson pulitzer prize-winning
writer David McCullough and journalists
mark steyn to name a few just recently
President Arne has established the Allen
p kirby center for constitutional
studies and citizenship which is located
in washington DC this center coordinates
classes and internships for the growing
number of students who go to Washington
as part of their work in government and
journalism the center works to deepen
Americans knowledge of the principles of
limited constitutional government
through a variety of programs and
publications dr. Aaron also recently
announced that the college foundation
founders campaign has been extended and
it's been extended to reach its
ambitious and important goals the major
capital and endowment campaign seeks to
secure one thing hillsdale's
independence and excellence in its
service to its 1844 mission in doing so
Hillsdale is serving the foundation of
this great country of ours many of you
who are here tonight helped helped in
this aerobic effort to date they've
received more than 531 million dollars
of cash pledges and trust towards the
goal of six hundred and eight million
dollars in closing I should also note
the doctor aren't is the author of
liberty and learning the evolution of
American education this book traces the
history of education in America it
explains the crisis of education today
and most important it outlines how this
crisis
be solved we again have complimentary
copies of this book available to you
after our dessert and reception so
please stop by and pick one of these up
hi thank you all for being here thank
you Gary good friend duh wow it's nice
crowd thank you a lot of old friends
here tonight and there's one that I
mentioned whenever I come back to
Southern California in Orange County
because he's such an old friend he's
very old now and and we're so blessed
and happy that he's alive he had a liver
transplant a year or so ago and I
figured out what it means because if
somebody has an organ changed it gives
you a test what did the organ do
anything that stays the same after the
organ has been changed was not
influenced by the organ and so I can
tell you that being charming and
friendly are not a product of the liver
being incredibly perceptive about human
relations are not caused by the liver
being anal retentive about events as you
think about that term you wouldn't think
it would be caused by the liver and it
is not that must come from somewhere
else and that man is Tom Fuentes who's
always a pleasure to see
I'm so honored tonight to have a
descendant of a great man seems a great
man to himself here and in I'll describe
is seen to you in January of 1863 in
hillsdale college there was we were on
the frontier the Civil War was in its
flower such as it was they were
basically no boys on the campus in
hillsdale there were 500 young men
recent graduates or graduate our current
students who taken leave serving in the
Union Army in July of that year about a
hundred of them were in the iron Brigade
at the Battle of Gettysburg and helped
to turn the battle so much so that two
of them were chosen to carry Lincoln's
casket from his from the Springfield
railway station to his final resting
place it's very manly very great very
courageous very honorable and of course
there were no boys on the campus and so
the people who brought Frederick
Douglass to the campus where the ladies
literary society and that was about the
only Society left on the campus and we
have the handwritten notes of the visit
of this very great man one of the most
famous photographs of him was taken on
that visit and we own an original print
of the photograph and I can tell you we
took in we paid Frederick Douglass the
amazing sum of fifty five dollars to
come and give a speech which is a lot of
money in 1863 and we took in in the gate
the minutes of the literary society show
110 bucks the college will not do that
while on me tonight
but the great great great is that right
how many great there three right
grandson of Frederick Douglass is here
tonight and his name is Kenny Morris
and you know there's a lot of famous
photographs of Frederick Douglass and
one of them's on his business card I
like I like the one taken at our campus
better but darned if he doesn't look
like him it's amazing welcome sir great
to have you and sometime during the
course of these remarks my daughter
katie is going to walk in here and then
she will become oh wow the most
important person in the room is not
Kenny Morris although that history is
really charming the most important
person in the room that I with all due
respect to all of the rest of you is the
proof that I married a beautiful woman
one Kathleen Arne please stand up katie
is teaching right now her first college
class monday wednesday friday and it's
very similar to a class that I'm
teaching all afternoon on monday
afternoon so on monday at the same hour
she and i are teaching the Constitution
united states and on Monday nights we
talk and it's a father never had such an
experience and wherever she's teaching
it's a very elite place
she's a better teacher than I am but the
kids are not as good you know and and
and she got this she gave me this report
you know one of the questions was you
know what do you do if they're kind of
you know surly and stuff you know and
resentful and don't pay attention and I
said I don't really know but I'm coming
out there she said that no you're not
but what would you do if you came and I
said well I'd throw the people out the
window and then the ones left in the
room would be the ones who want to be
there and that would be a better class
but I think she's conquering them now
and I'm not surprised could you know
isn't she pretty
okay I have a just a few points to make
and I about a quarter of you are here I
think because you you wish to enroll in
hillsdale college and or your parents
are here with you to help you make that
decision and so I'm going to address a
few things specifically to you how many
are at a hillsdale college event for the
first time hi Wow lot thank you for
coming oh I see Tom take back their top
and Tom Tate is one of my very favorite
he runs an engineering firm here in
Southern California and he's a great guy
and he sends his children to the wrong
College us see what good football team
so before i'm done i have to achieve
this you have to know what the college
is and how it might be relevant to the
lives we all live today and if I'm
successful you will know those two
things and i can tell you you probably
don't know either of them now because
almost no one knows what a college is
today i'll try to tell you and I'm going
to feature that because of these
students who might show up because if I
don't teach them now before they show up
I might have to throw them out the
window
I mentioned four things about the
college at the start one of them is it's
old and you have to understand about the
wageworks among corporate things you
actually live in the oldest country on
Earth and the oldest country in the
history of the earth and the reason is
the philosopher as I call him Aristotle
says if you watch a play and they have a
chorus in the play and the chorus
members don't change but they come out
in their comic chorus and then they
leave and then they come back later and
they're a tragic chorus even though the
members are the same it's not the same
course because organizations are defined
by what they are for the United States
of America is the clearest possible
country in all of human history in
stating at the outset what it is for and
also the manner by which it will be
governed there's never been anything in
all the political history so coherent is
that and as long as we keep that and
right now we are in a great battle to
decide whether we will keep that and do
not think for a minute that that battle
is lost because it is not lost and I can
also tell you that I will assert to you
and I will prove it before I done that
it is not going to be lost because we
will not have it it must
and our college is old in that sense
because it was founded in 1844 with a
very beautiful document and that
document pledges us to the cause of
civil and religious freedom and
intelligent piety the first two being
political goods they are in fact
specifically America's gift to the world
no people on earth ever enjoyed the
blessings of civil and religious freedom
before the people of the United States
of America endure enjoyed it the mother
of that girl right over there is from
England and England the best country in
the world before we were born got those
blessings after we did and that is a
simple historical fact and we began with
a pledge to support those principles
through sound learning and we never have
a board meeting at Hillsdale College
that we do not begin with a reading from
that document and all there though there
are older colleges than are 166 years I
do not know of any that have no purpose
in them except the first purpose by
which they were begun and the first
thing all you prospective students must
know is that if you are admitted to our
College then you will get a letter from
me in June that contains a copy of the
honor code and the honor code quotes
from that document and the letter will
say that if if you come to our College
at Station one in the registration
process you will hand in this code and
if you do not you cannot go to station
two and so do not come unless you
yourself are pledged as the board is
pledged and as every member of the
faculty and the staff are placed and is
that I myself personally am pledged to
support the principles of the college
and that makes it the oldest college on
the face of the earth
the second thing about the college's it
has always had a part in the great
affairs of the nation on the second of
July 1863 a very great general by the
name of Buford a cavalry Jenner general
decided to hold some ground and he sent
so many messages up the road saying run
up here and help me because I'll get
killed if you don't but if you come
really fast we can hold this and we can
change the world and it just so happened
the guy who got this message was a guy
named Reynolds who was very great man
himself and he was killed on that day
about 10 minutes after if I arriving at
the battlefield but he read this thing
and you know who this guy Buford was and
he turned around to his colleagues in
the iron Brigade and he said we're going
to run down that road we're going to run
as fast as we can go and they got there
and by nightfall two thirds of them were
dead and among the survivors were
several from Hillsdale two of whom won
the Congressional Medal of Honor and
those two it turns out because were
chosen to bear Lincoln's casket and then
as now at Hillsdale College we have no
military training of any kind and yet
then as now we probably have certainly
then and I think now more young men and
women join the military than any college
pound-for-pound size for size in the
land I do have this from a Marine Corps
recruiter he said that I've been doing
this for six years now and I've got 70
colleges and you're the smallest and
most of the colleges have not had
anybody joined the Marine Corps in this
years that I've been here and none has
had more than one except you and you
have six this year and that's typical
add to that that when the Republican
Party a long time back ago when it
before it became the stupid party
because it was actually founded as the
brilliant party I mean there's never
been anything better in all the
political history i asserted i can prove
it they found a constitutional way to
get rid of human slavery and that meant
that the Declaration of Independence and
the Constitution could be rejoined us
they were meant to be and the first
platform convention of the Republican
Party was written in Jackson Michigan by
12 people and two of them worked at
Hillsdale College one of them was the
Civil War governor and the other was a
civil war lieutenant governor of
Michigan they sent the troops to Lincoln
which is why there were so many from
Michigan and they themselves by the way
had not been trained in anything except
the things we train people in today
because if you come to house till
College you must know this that you will
spend the first two years studying what
everybody else is studying you will read
really old books and they're hard and
they are great and that you will write
papers about them and the professor's
would place ridding all over the papers
an essentially frustrating experience
and it will lay the ground for the rest
of your life to know the most important
things and today like back then we
always thought we should come forward
and be of service and remember the model
of America and this too is unique in
America nothing before it was ever like
this the model was that ordinary folk in
their natural equality and their natural
rights would control and contribute to
the government and there would be no
born sovereign among us and in the
spirit of that back when in 1844 we took
these kids who were nobodies and we gave
them the education as fancy as the
education that Plato himself gave his
students because they had the two
natural qualifications to which any
human being may have they were willing
and they were able and birth does not
matter nothing matters I would like to
say that my daughter is the
brilliant woman she is because she is my
daughter but alas human affairs do not
work that way she is just a blessing
today what we do is a model of what we
did then we don't take any money from
the government right now I'm busy trying
to found a private ROTC program because
we got so many kids going in the Army in
the Navy and the Marines and the Air
Force and we can't take the money from
the government for rotc because they
would make us obey there are several
hundred pages of some stupid regulations
so what I've almost close to with the
deal with the Marine Corps is they're
going to appoint an officer to live
somewhere nearby and they and our
students can report to them and will
provide all the rest of the money but
that is only a microcosm of what every
private organization in America has
always done when it's been good which is
it has done for its country from its
independence and its freedom and today
we do that today so the country the
college is old it is faithful it is
moral we don't have coed dorms and i can
tell you when you get there especially
you young men the girls are really
attractive
too bad and the last thing about the
college that I'll mention is it's a
liberal arts college and I was just
talking to mr. Sabo who looks like a
decathlete he's back there somewhere I
see him and he's very energetic and
enthusiastic and he's very open he wants
to come to our college and so if he
asked him a question he spits out an
answer and before he can reply to that
when he says the second one too and
they're both wrong and and so it was
good though I like him he's going to
this is as I said this is a dog little
hot and and so I got him to you know
talk about the purpose of life and I got
him to say that happiness was the
purpose of life after he tried about six
other things and then I got him to
define happiness and he defined it as
financial security and I raised the
question was anybody rich and miserable
and he said he heard of such people acid
so it wouldn't just be financial
security would it any winch in health
you know he's a very good-looking kid
and he's very healthy he's very athletic
guy looks like he can't lead as I say
and he said yeah that would be at two
and I said anybody healthy and rich
who's miserable and he said yeah maybe
there were some and I said so what would
you add or put the question another way
to put it in political terms because
this will come up again in a minute when
i'm going to talk thanks i guess i'm
talking now
how is the Declaration of Independence
written it's a very extraordinary
document because it's a war document you
know the end all these rich well-placed
prominent men in a room in Philadelphia
that exist still today but their
signatures on a document that was an act
of treason against the strongest living
man and they mutually pledge to each
other their lives and their fortunes and
their sacred honor and that's the end of
the document it's incredibly particular
but the beginning of it is simply
universal they had to have a
justification for what they did outside
their own will and so they wrote one
they said that sometimes it comes up in
human history or when in the course of
human events not just now any old time
it becomes necessary for one people to
dissolve the political bands that have
connected them to another and to assume
among the powers of the earth the
separate and equal station to which the
laws of nature and of nature's God
entitle you and the question before the
house in any class at Hillsdale College
that's any good as always what are those
laws how do you know their meaning and
what if somebody disagrees is the truth
still self-evident if somebody says it
isn't so I'm going to quote Barack Obama
about that to you in a minute just what
he says
a liberal education is the education
that lets you define a meaning to the
expression the laws of nature and of
nature's God or that lets young
ambitious Mr Sabo back here and all
these other kids in this room who might
come to our college to know what is the
purpose of their life because they're
not a mule and they're not a dog and
they're not a rooster they have their
purposes and they're not an angel they
have their purposes they are human
beings what is the right way as
Secretary Socrates for a human being to
live is if there is an answer to that
question and liberal education is about
that and I said to mr. Sabel back there
I said I might teach to give that answer
and he said if I come to your college
and I said yeah and I can promise you
something if you graduate you will know
and if you don't know you won't graduate
so those are my four points about the
college that's what we do my second and
penultimate point i'm tempted to
challenge somebody to define penultimate
is what is happening in the world and
what does it tell us about education and
about colleges i'm going to begin with
the story it's pertinent because it's a
opposite in time it happened last week
there was a class in a fancy graduate
school in washington DC and in this
class was sitting one stephanie Francel
a student of mine who's now often a
fancy graduate school and she writes me
a thank you letter after this class
because the class was horrific to her
the class was taught by a senior
official in the Reagan administration
the Reagan administration they had an
exercise in which they were asked to
list qualities of leaders someone
suggested manipulation and my student
replied but that involves deceit and
that cannot be a good trade for a leader
I'm quoting by the way from an email
that Stephanie robbed me the response
came when she said this from the teacher
but they were not looking for good
leaders but effective leaders because
leadership involves certain effects that
are common among all leaders good and
bad and then they talked about this and
somebody said well there's Hitler and
the lady actually said well you know
Hitler was a very effective leader and
you know in one point of view he was
because in about nineteen eleven let's
say he was living in the street he
didn't have a place to sleep her way to
take a shower he smelled really bad and
he looked worse and he was a street bum
he can only make a living by selling
paintings and they were bad paintings it
was a poor artist they were tourists
painting
his broker was a Jew something always
presented and took his vengeance and now
then so that's about 1911 and by 1934 he
is the ruler of what was probably at
that moment the greatest power on earth
and it had reorganized Europe and it was
going on a career of conquest that would
take it to the gates of Moscow and all
the way to the Atlantic Ocean now that's
effective but how did it end up alone
his country in ruin himself isolated
shooting himself in a bunker having
watched the death seconds before of the
only woman he could ever say that he
loved and he treated her like a tool all
his life as he did everything else
around him in other words he died in the
condition of misery and squalor to which
he was entitled by his every deed and my
student stephanie is a little impatient
that the distinction between a leader
and a tyrant is not the distinction that
they are after in the book that made me
a student I was going to be a lawyer I
had to take this course in college and
it was on Plato's Republic and in the
first book of Plato's Republic there's
this discussion and it's one of the most
magical things ever written one of the
most meaningful one of the most
significant one of the most eternally
meaningful discussions all of you young
people should decide whether you come to
Hillsdale College on the basis of
whether you want to know the answer the
answer to the question that I'm about to
ask because this office guy who's a job
is to teach ambitious young people how
to be powerful and they pay him money
for that and he his argument in the
first book of Plato's Republic is that
justice is the interest of the strongest
person whoever that is and Socrates
refutes him by saying well good okay so
let's say you're the strongest then what
you should you do what is your interest
what will you do with your power in
other words it's a very simple point
power only raises the question what will
you do with it you see and we all have
to answer that question all the time and
Socrates banishes this guy and he's very
angry he's a jerk and also his
livelihood is threatened because
Socrates doesn't charge money and so
then this young man this bold young man
says Glaucon is his name show me then
Socrates that justice is the right thing
even if by practicing it you win the
reputation for injustice and that seemed
to me when I first heard that that was
in the year nineteen seventy-four in
about March and I can remember the color
of the walls in the room it was so
dramatic and I thought them as up I want
to know the answer to that question I
want to know what I asked Mr Sabo what
is the thing that you can do that can
make you fully human and can make your
life worth living no matter what the
cost you might have to pay for it what
is the thing that you would say to your
daughter she must do regardless of the
cost because then our life will be
meaningful and right and I'm saying that
my student stephanie is offended because
that is the question that is excluded in
this college today a famous college
about two miles from the White House
I needed done in the White House
communications director I'll make this a
nonpartisan point because I've said this
first person the teacher in the class is
a Reagan administration official and
since I said the name you needa done I
would say the name Constance Newman who
is the director of White House personnel
management in the Reagan administration
she's the teacher in the class I needed
done is the White House communications
director and she says to bunch of
schoolchildren the other day you know
because when you get to be in the White
House you're like really wise and you
can talk to the young and preach at them
and tell them what to do the third
lesson she says and tip actually come
from to my favorite political
philosophers not say son and mother
Teresa in 1947 when Mao was being
challenged within his own party on his
plan to basically take China over the
nationalist Chinese held the cities they
had the army they had the Air Force they
had everything on their side how can you
win said people to poor little mal you
know aspiring ruler little now in his
britches and his hopes right how can you
do this against all the odds against you
and he said you fight your war and I'll
fight mine that's her point right and
impressed upon this letter she said you
know maybe he didn't do everything right
but he lived his dream and there's an
argument among historians did he kill 40
or did he kill 70 million and by the way
a variability of 30 million that's a big
variation that means you got to really
kill a lot of people for the uncertainty
level to be that high so you see the
point something has happened in this
country correlate to developments in the
one development the government does not
operate at all the way it used to be
there is this constitution written it is
simply the best thing
like it ever done and that is without
any controversy nothing has lasted so
long or done so well and and we don't
act like it says what it says you see
it's a simple document you can read it
in 20 minutes and it does not have the
bearing it used to have that's one
development I'm going to write a book if
I can the summer i think i can because
the idea came to me walking around
washington DC and in the book i'm going
to say that there are these beautiful
buildings in washington DC and there are
these ugly buildings in washington DC
and all of the ugly buildings were built
recently and all of the beautiful
buildings were built a long time ago and
everything that goes on in the beautiful
buildings is justified by the
Constitution United States and
everything that goes on in the ugly
buildings is not by the way do you ever
look at the department of education you
know what it looks like i'm going to put
pictures i'm going to put fancy picture
i'm going to send my boy off to
Washington take a lot of pictures he
likes to take pictures and and if you
look at the Capitol what's the first
thing you notice about the Capitol the
shapes are round at the Capitol the
circle is the perfect shape the second
thing it points up right do you know
what the department of education
building looks like do you know where
the word bureaucracy comes from it comes
from a desk with lots of slots to put
stuff in it looks like such a desk
standing up there and what's in the
slots as people bureaucrats people
occupy the slots you ever go around the
California Capitol building go some time
with my friend Tom McClintock he's in
Congress now thank God for it but when
he was in Sacramento and he gets back
there sometimes he's cut his district is
up that way now he's a carpetbagger
he's just a really great congressman I
mean really great he's awesome and he
took me on a tour one time and the Old
Capitol building there are not very many
offices and they have an enormous
dignity see but if you're in the a
bureaucrat in the Department of
Education you've got your slot and the
slot is not really a human thing to have
the architectural method of
constitutional reform and I'm saying
that change is enormous and just as the
Constitution and its structure are
proved are argued for as a institutional
representation of the meaning of the
declaration of independence in the
Federalist Papers so the new kind of
government has a new idea behind it and
it's not the same as the idea of the
Declaration of Independence and that
means before i prove that that we are in
a fight for the central core of our
country and if the fight goes the wrong
way we will be reduced to the simple
material that is the doctrine of modern
government that in fact we are and so
I'm saying that these developments are
not accidental they're not just some
gradual step-by-step development the
kind of government we have today is
being chosen even by the way against the
public wishes made more urgent because
the public does not wish it because a
new principal justifies the new thing
and so do you see what happens there's
an argument going on about the meaning
of man and the meaning of governor
and our freedom and our civilization
depend upon the outcome of that argument
and I believe that is as simple as 123
and that means by the way it follows and
it cannot be resisted that it follows
that nothing is so urgent as to
understand the terms of that argument
and I will tell you that the politicians
who resist the trend of things to the
day for the most part do not understand
the argument most of the ones who are
pushing the trend very much do but their
opponents are confused why for example
as the Congress never passed the Equal
Opportunity Act do you know what it is
it's the California Civil Rights
initiative at the federal level and did
you know that there have been eight
years I think of Republican control of
both houses of Congress and the
presidency and they have never passed
that act and every time it is put on the
ballot in Michigan for God's sake Ward
Connerly is a friend of mine I was the
chairman of the California Civil Rights
initiative before he was one of the
greatest acts of persuasion I ever
committed in my life was to persuade him
to take my job and he said to me you
know what he said I'll say this because
the descendant of fred douglas is here
tonight is a good thing to say in front
of him he looked at me across the table
one day and he said you think this is
easier for me than it is for you and I
said I don't know what I think about
that ward I said I think you'll be
better at it than I will and he said why
cuz I'm black and I said that's part of
it but the real reason I said is
somebody should run this thing who wants
to be the governor of california and i
don't i have too good a job for that and
I can teach you know I should teach
people that's not what I should do you
should do this and he said but I'll do
it he said I think but he said you have
to know it's harder
for me because he said if I do it I'm
betraying something that's what they
expect from you and I you know one time
I took a red-eye with him to Washington
DC to get up early in the morning we
flew through Chicago so he couldn't
sleep on the plane and we took a red-eye
and we went to ask a bunch of
congressmen to endorse us and they
didn't the vain effort they should have
to one of my held up while he was we
were in the conference he passed out
some articles he wrote and one of them
had the name of Abraham Lincoln in the
title and he was talking on blah blah
blah blah about why he wouldn't endorse
it and I held up that article and he
finally got distracted and he said what
what I said did you rent this article
and he said I did and I said name a
Lincoln here in the title he said yeah I
said what were you saying again he said
it's not as simple as that I said you
know you never heard Lincoln say that
why won't they pass that why has the
government grown in places where it's
got no business being under
administration's of both types and I
will argue that it's not because the
people in Congress are our Craven really
in either party it's that one party has
a new principle of Justice it espouses
and another party is confused and they
can't meet head on the claim that
limited government is not the right way
to go and that means they can't make the
argument against the incredible growth
of the entitlement state and so their
arguments are mostly about efficiency I
you know when Obama spoke in baltimore
to the republicans i was out there i
spoke after him i was better
it's not a high standard I mean that it
isn't I'm gonna explain in a minute
right but what was it like there's about
20 or 30 of them and wow they're good
they have the gift I turned back to you
young people do you know what it takes
to learn I can't teach you you have to
learn and you have to be humble and
assertive at the same time you have to
dare to want to know the very best
things and you have to possess your soul
in complete discipline and patience to
attend to those things can you sit down
I asked a kid tonight and study hard for
three hours without getting up and given
it your whole attention and he said I
can and that's a good i'll find out the
truth of that because there's two kinds
you can do that or you don't get through
because that's what it takes right you
have to have self control of a wonderful
kind to be a great student and learning
to be a student is to practice doing
that and it's hard it's just really
great and at our college by the way
don't get the idea we beat you up we
don't I mean we do a little bit but I
mean we kind of do but the real point is
this these standards that I'm talking
about we don't make them there there we
just try to help you meet them and
you'll get nothing but encouragement
from us and also probably B's and C's
but that's because the standards are
high we didn't make them and and that
means by the way if you ever study the
great moments in American history the
ones that went well you will always find
some divinely gifted soul who had all
the virtues and they could put things in
their simplicity and their fundamental
meaning and they staked their lives on
that so Thomas Jefferson rich farmer and
George Washington
rich farmer signed that paper and they
knew what it meant when they did and
Jefferson had the eloquence to write the
paper and giant and James Madison had
the wisdom to write the other paper the
Constitution and George Washington had
the courage in his soul to put the army
in the field and defend the papers and
I'm saying that those are the only
political virtues that matter in a
crisis and those virtues depend upon the
kind of learning we will make the
argument truly and beautifully and we
will stick our lives on it or we will
lose because that is how it has always
been that means that the standards of
greatness that are set by Lincoln and
Washington are the necessary standards
for the crisis today and we have no
purpose except to strive to emulate
those standards and know if we have
striven with all our hearts that it will
not matter win or lose because we will
have lived well at the Battle of Trenton
when they're going across the Delaware
River because they're going to attack
the Hessians on Christmas night hoping
they'll be drunk because they can't beat
them if they're not drunk right and they
got to beat them because there isn't any
more time and that Glover says to
Washington you were late general we're
going to get there after dawn and you
said we couldn't beat them unless we got
them before dawn are we going to turn
back in Washington said no we're going
to go on and Glover who was a very brave
man said how can that be and he said
look either way we're going to be dead
in a week if we don't win this battle
we're going to go on down the road and
we're going to win in the face of the
enemy all his riches all his fame
everything about it they meant nothing
to him because the only thing that meant
anything to him was that he would not be
ruled by any man claiming to be born to
rule him because of who his father was
or any other principle except his own
consent and he would rather die in the
cause of defending that even
ignominiously even having no name or
fame than to live well under the
patronage of another and we would not
have our country today except for the
clear sight that defined such things so
awesomely with such blistering clarity
you can hardly bear to look at it it's
like trying to stare at the Sun and then
the courage to back it up and don't make
a mistake about what's going on we are
building a nomenklatura among loss right
now do you know what that word means
it's from the Soviet days it's the
Russian word for a list of names and the
nomenclature ax were a specialized class
of people with a lot of power and and
the name is a derisory name because the
principle of communism is you don't get
to have a name jewelry darkness at noon
by arthur koestler to read 1984 by
george orwell the point is communism
requires to extinguish humanity and what
happened was by the way in this high
principal militant philosopher
revolution what they ended up with was a
bunch of corrupt officials we started
our recession that we're having right
now where unemployment rates are
probably north of fifteen percent in
September of 2008 do you know how many
people in the United States Department
of Transportation made more than a
hundred and seventy grand in august of
2008 do you know how many do today 1692
the plan is the principle is easy to
state this is in the words of woodrow
wilson i can show you where he wrote
this and just these many words it's not
it's not an elaboration it's not
anything what he said so what he wrote
and he's an academic he's responsible or
what he writes he said the Declaration
of Independence is obsolete we now know
that human societies must be living and
changing things they were accountable to
Newton in nature and now we know about
Darwin but you see because we know that
everything is changed what was the
campaign slogan the opportunity arises
for us to manage the change and we can
be in control of everything we can
appoint a class of highly trained people
and they can manage the society where
are the gains in the health care bill
under the old system here's where they
were I'm the side of a school teacher in
Pocahontas Arkansas he grew up in a
place where nobody ever went to college
he went right if I'd been interested in
biology and stuff like that I probably
would end up being a medical doctor as I
almost ended up being a lawyer and why
because my dad had gone to college have
been a schoolteacher and I could have
been unfortunate i could have been born
to some rich guy i was born to a guy
who'd like to read books and he and i
had to work i didn't have any money what
fortune i had and so things like that is
how you become a doctor see and I've
already told you I have learned from
being a teacher that I'm pretty good at
my job and I know stuff and I know stuff
because I love the stuff energy you know
I can talk about it I practiced it moves
me deeply but I have found in the
classroom that I do not teach them they
learn and so I have to organize
everything with my colleagues so that
they show up ready to go i teach monday
afternoon from two
24 30 what a dreary exercise and once in
a while you know I'll say to him wow are
we not ready to do this today I can
prove it to you the philosopher teaches
that this is the highest thing of which
a human being is capable and you've
shown up today and you're sleeping
really can that be I got Girl Scout
cookies if you want them but we got work
to do get up huh and they do I tell you
they just sit up you know and they're
just ready to go see that's how you make
a doctor that's how you make a lawyer
and then after you make one then some
free person has some kids and they they
have a wife and a husband and they take
care of themselves and they go to the
doctor free people cooperating and
building their lives too that's how you
make a healthcare system and the plan
today released last week is that there
will be a national board to set rates
and methods of service by some experts
who make 170 grand in the Department of
Education the Republican Secretary of
Education says we started out as a
little small office just gathering data
and now we're 5500 strong with our
computers and our blackberries and I'll
tell you what every single one of the
5500 has in common there's not a teacher
in the crowd and what they do is they
make their hundred and seventy grand and
they don't build any roads and they
don't teach any students they sit around
and talk about a distant thing and try
to organize it by rules from above and
they think that that is the key to all
progress in human society and if they
get their way they will become numerous
enough that it won't matter how the rest
of them vote and you could lose control
of your
from it over that and you must not let
that happen and so I will close with
these points
if you think how the Declaration of
Independence is written you will see
that today well I'll read it to you it's
a quote implicit in the Constitution
structure this is written by a man who
took an oath to uphold the Constitution
as a condition of high public service
employment implicit in the Constitution
structure in the very idea of ordered
Liberty was a rejection of absolute
truth the infallibility of any idea any
tyrannical consistency that might block
future generations into a single
unalterable course audacity of hope
Barack Obama who took an oath to uphold
the Constitution
in the nature of this country public
opinion is sovereign until it uses loses
its constitutional forms public opinion
is in pretty good shape as things go the
purpose of the movement is to make
public opinion no longer sovereign but
to elevate expert opinion not in the
name of despotism but in the name of a
kind of perfection designed by human
beings that is the movement that is can
control of the government there is an
insufficient resistance to that but
already in power there are people who
have the minds of students and statesmen
and they know enough and they should be
supported the single thing that must be
added to the situation today is a
standard of statesmanship built upon a
kind of learning that will uphold the
laws of nature and of nature's God and
make the Constitution of the United
States function again as it is supposed
to do and so I just named two components
and one of those components is supplied
by teaching and learning and guess what
I do for a living Hillsdale College in
its history has come forth to help the
country at parallel to itself and today
I promise you there is no danger it will
not run to serve the principles upon
which it was born and I thank you for
your interest in your help
it's an honor to allow some time for
some questions we have time for one or
two questions and I really encourage you
to take advantage of the brilliance and
the thoughts in this room so do we have
a question out there please raise yes
sir this is one of the best no seriously
one of the best instructions I've had in
the past five years what's happening to
us politically and this is sort of a
question do you think dr. Arnn that the
American people in their current state
of ignorance and dis education by the
teachers in the public sector can rise
to the fore and do what we did in 1776 I
do yeah I do the end of sort answer is
yes Carl and thank you the longer answer
is not very long what they teach in
colleges today is hard to learn because
like they teach that I mean what you
know by the way since three thousand
years the chief political question is
what is the nature of good versus evil
rule and they actually teaching by the
way it's kind of a bipartisan effort and
you know the stupid party is in my
opinion you know I'm a member of the
stupid party and I support it very
strongly and to get better but it's got
to get smart so the point the point is
what they teach in colleges thank God
most people don't learn it very well cuz
and you know most people get out of
college and and what do they do they get
married and they get a family and they
get a job and they might start a
business and they go to church and they
have life experience and life experience
is pretty close to nature so what I
think is it's not an accident that this
is a problem of elite opinion in the
main and I do think that we need so
first of all I think the people are
reliable and I think if they become
unreliable we're finished so and and you
know I studied Winston Churchill for a
long time I'm at Kitty's mother over
there doing that and and what did you
learn from that it looked dark right but
trust because they do have the right to
govern themselves and it's not for us to
take that away from them what do you
need to add first of all you know right
after the election because we we have
this Center in Washington now I bought a
building we the college I mean I did it
I guess but the college bought this
really cool building right on Capitol
Hill and we're going to open it on
September 17th Constitution Day this
year have a big gala celebration and we
got a hundred kids a year going there
now to study and we got 60 congressional
staffers and stuff studying the
Constitution with us and some partners
heritage and some others and we got a
bunch of congressmen who are friends of
mine mostly they're all friends of Tom
Tate and Tom Fuentes almost all of them
that I know and you know the really good
ones are really great and so what I
think is what a value added is is teach
them because we're going to have to you
know let's put the point straight we're
going to have to first limit and then
gradually dismantle the entitlement
state and we're never going to get that
done unless we have a principle of
justice to justify it something that we
stand up and say we won't do that that's
not right this is the right thing nobody
ever imagined
and revolution the stuff that goes on
today it has to be spewed out of our
mouths and we have to persuade people
that their instinct is correct so I
think that the problem is not among the
great many and you know look there's 400
you guys here tonight and we send of me
a newsletter out too because you don't
think of my experience the department of
education budget has gone up
thirty-three percent in the current
budget just submitted and I actually
think given what they do with the money
it would be better if they piled it up
in the parking lot and burned it and and
that's money to my competitors thank god
they're so wasteful how would I ever
keep up but what we have is you guys and
nobody ever makes it you know I haven't
asked you for any money tonight I'm not
going on if you want to give you'll give
and you'll find a way just like going to
med school just like everything you'll
take care of yourselves right and if you
think will help you do that serve the
causes you love so that's a very and i
live on that in in october of 2008 what
did I think right the capital markets
are going down Obama is talking about a
cap on the deductible ative charitable
contributions and free tuition for every
kid in America to college those are my
three revenue streams right and what
have we done you know told him to stick
it again so what I think is I have the
vindication of that experience we're
here so I carlin I'm pretty optimistic
about the people and I'm meaning for us
to get optimistic about their leaders
but we got some work to do there yes I
God
well we're unique yeah we're pretty good
and I you know what what what's right
what's first of all you can't work in a
college without having a fair amount of
humility there's a lot of problems you
know but come visit hundreds do every
year and what you'll find out is the
people show up ready to work my
competitor is like one of my near
competitors in the Midwest just
announced that they're cutting eight
percent of their faculty for failures of
admissions failures of student body
enrollment and you know every time they
get a kid they get a bunch of money from
the government coming with them even
though they're a private liberal arts
college our applications this year up
twenty percent and they're already high
they've been going up eight and ten
percent a year but now they gone up
twenty percent so a lot of things are
right about our college and I first of
all don't think it takes so many is that
but second we've been very successful in
we get emulators now and God bless them
I hope they really do what they say so
and and and I don't want you to think
it's a numbers game because see what
Carl said and I think sir implicit in
your question is a think that I actually
think is a misunderstanding like here's
just a fact right the public education
system is bad it's been bad for a long
time that's fact one fact to the correct
president united states has the lowest
approval ratings of any president since
after a year since they've been taking
polls now
is that a problem with public opinion I
don't think so i think that I I think
that we need a certain kind of learning
to become sovereign first among a few
people and you know how many hillsdale
college graduates are here tonight you
know there's some and the old ones you
know it wasn't it hard back then but
with it was hard sorry I have to do that
and the young ones you know like I got a
kid and and you know how many people led
the American Revolution and I'm not
saying the ones who lead our country are
all going to come from Hillsdale College
they won't it's just that the number is
going to be finite and we're going to be
talking to them and we can help and
remember this too i should say this
because it's a very important point of
humility there are two kinds of really
great teachers one kind we can make real
smart get the light in there I can't
talk any ambitious subject or that I'm
sitting up and getting going and they're
going to do a lot and then there's
Abraham Lincoln and Winston Churchill
and George Washington God makes them I
don't there's just a special gift and so
part of part of the curious thing about
great affairs in the life of nations is
you get that or you don't in fact in
some of the great old philosophic books
that level of political ability is
treated as a synonym for chance so first
of all about your question I don't think
it's a numbers game I think a good
college can do a lot and there's a few
pretty good ones and we were pretty
prominent and so we're going to make a
difference and if we win over time then
there's no reason at all why the
education system can't gradually become
very solid everywhere it took it about a
hundred years to go rotten you know and
you know rotten is not the natural
tendency so maybe it'll take 50 or 60
years for it to get better if we can win
some battles so I guess that's my
thought
that got me yes sir dr. Arnn I'm Raghu
Mathur Chancellor of local South Orange
County Community College District oh
yeah you're part of that mafia yeah
along with Fuentes probably uh huh is it
distinguished mr. Fuentes is a
distinguished member of our Board of
Trustees and really we really love and
revere him there my question is
hillsdale college is no question a great
college what are we going to do about
the public education system across
America you mentioned that there are a
lot of challenges and they can become
great maybe in 60 or 70 years but what
do they need to do now so that they
could become great well in 60 or 70
years yeah I'll repeat and embellish
first of all you can't fix it all now it
can't be done right cuz they're you know
here's what makes here's what you get
you just have to get one thing right I
can tell you you just have to get one
thing right to make a college really
successful everything
and I I just can't tell you how much I
mean that they gotta you know when I got
there and hillsdale I wanted one of the
best things I do is I eat with the
students in the dining hall a lot and my
predecessor didn't very much and he was
good I'm not criticizing him but what I
found out was about twenty percent of
the students were really mad at us and I
couldn't figure why they were mad and
they were mad because we had a lot of
rules and they weren't there rules
that's why we have an honor code that's
why I said all that stuff to you guys
because remember you sign that document
you're stuck I had a boy we had a really
good football team this year there was a
boy on the football team and he was
misbehaving and it was am it's rare i
almost never have a discipline meeting
with the student but this kid was kind
of tough on the Dean women in the dean
of men and I heard what he said to them
and I got really angry and I dragged him
in there and I you know I had his own
from five years ago I had his honor code
and I set him down I said did you sign
that document that you and he said yes
sir I said huh Wow read that to me and
he reads it and I said you you Santa he
said yeah and then I got his fraternity
pledge and I said you took that pledge
did you he said yeah I said read it and
he read it and I said the highlighted
sentence read it again honor to women
upon all occasions he said a foul word
in front of my Dean of women I said did
you say a foul word in front of my Dean
of women and he got small he's a big old
boy you know and I said and you and you
took that oath shame
I said you know why I don't throw you
out that window it's not because you're
big I can I'm so angry but I can do so
much worse to you and and remember you
don't have any cause to complain because
you swore your own oath the word college
means partnership you all got to sign up
you can make it great if you do it
together now the point is you're not
going to fix the public schools quick if
that's what it takes to fix them make
options I got a deal to offer you if you
will form a charter school and get it
through so that it can be well run we
will supply you and pay a headmaster for
seven years and we will supply you a
curriculum and we will train the faculty
and that will cost us about a hundred
grand a year and we have the money and
we're going to start doing that all over
the country
so as I say it's not a numbers game but
there are some numbers and and we should
probably go eat dessert now and you guys
are great bless you all thank you